thank you for joining us America we're
glad you're here this is the Dave Ramsey
show in the lobby of Ramsey solutions
Barrett and Moe are with us hey guys how
are ya we are greater than we deserve
how are you James just the same what do
you guys live San Antonio and all the
way from there to do it debt-free
screaming Nashville yes I love it how
much have you paid off just under
$220,000 all right very cool and how
long did that take just under seven
years all right very cool and that your
range of income during those years we
started at about 90 and it's not quite
doubled during that time okay so like a
hundred and seventy yourself all right
very cool good for you guys so I'm
guessing this is your mortgage and
everything actually no this is a little
bit of carbon mainly student loans lots
of student loans yes sir
and what are your degrees in let's count
on no it's limits that we met in law
school actually Dave okay so your
lawyers yes sir all right very good very
cool
good so tell me the story the seven-year
slog that through this it was a slog at
some times it seemed and shortly after
he got married which was about eight
years ago my mom introduced us to you
gave us a total money makeover book and
we kind of ignored it for a little bit
but finally got on board and we're
looking at these student loans just
going oh my goodness how are we going to
deal with this because it was just this
huge number and we had so many friends
going out after we graduated from law
school and buying new cars and buying
houses and we're looking at what we had
and the loans that we had going there's
no way that we can do that what is going
on and so finally sat down read your
book went to one of the Total Money
Makeover live events and were sold and
so we haven't been perfect along this
journey obviously it took us seven years
but when we fell down we got back on
track and we are so excited just to be
done with Sallie Mae she is gone and we
could not be more thrilled obviously
your income went up dramatically during
that time so
it I'm gonna guess and think maybe there
was a big run on the bank late here I
mean you made a big big bunch of it in
maybe the last two years or something
yes and you also might have seen the two
little ones that are running around that
also came in that seven years oh yeah
okay we have a four year old in a 16
month old that Oh perfect
okay I've added to our number and what
are their names foster is our son is
four and Hattie Jane is our daughter all
right very cool very cool
so I probably got some loggers out there
with big law school debt listening yeah
what do you tell them the secret to
getting out of data as you paid off
$220,000 staying focused and having
someone that will keep you accountable
whether that's a spouse if you're
married or a friend or a family member
it's easy to get off track when there's
no one there making sure that you're
doing the right thing so I think a big
thing for us was keeping each other
accountable and also we had some family
members that really helped keep us
accountable along the way as well very
cool and put off the new cars put off
the vacations that that can come later
absolutely much sweeter now now you're
clear you've come on our first family
vacation to see you
Wow well we're honored to have you here
thanks for coming by Barry Cole will
congratulations Barrett and Mo foster
and Hattie from San Antonio Texas I'm
gonna try to get them into the picture
maybe a little bit alright and $220,000
paid off in seven years making 90 up to
170 a year count it down let's hear a
debt free scream three two
well done well done you guys that's
fabulous that's how it's done right
there hey guys thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show and so you have to
break the cycle you have to flip this
thing on its head and make it behave
you've got to get so fired up and wired
up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind